knowing the mass of an object actually
tells you two independent things
about that object for instance if you
knew that this truck had a large mass
you'd know that it has a large amount of
inertia that is to say
it'd be very reluctant to being
accelerated it'd be difficult to speed
up and once you got it up to speed
it'd be very difficult to stop it would
take a large amount of force
that's because it has a large amount of
inertial mass and
this idea of inertial mass is best
exemplified with
newton's second law so acceleration
equals the net
force divided by m this
m right here down here in the
denominator this is the
inertial mass because it's telling you
how reluctant that thing is to be
accelerated more inertial mass would
give you less acceleration
but mass also tells you something else
it tells you how much that object is
going to
interact via gravity so if this truck
has a large mass
that also tells you its force of gravity
is going to be very large
so the force of gravity fg on this truck
is equal to
m g but this m right here is not
inertial mass
this m here is telling you how much this
truck interacts
via gravity with other objects that
means this is the gravitational mass
now in our universe for a given object
these two values
inertial mass and gravitational mass are
going to be the same so this truck's
inertial mass
measured in kilograms is going to be the
exact same value
as this truck's gravitational mass
measured in kilograms but it didn't have
to be that way i mean these two ideas
are conceptually different
one the inertial mass tells you how much
inertia or reluctance to acceleration
something has but the gravitational mass
tells you how much that object interacts
via gravity so you can imagine a
universe
where maybe there's no force of gravity
but objects still have a reluctance to
being accelerated by
other forces or maybe you can imagine a
universe
where there is a force of gravity but
the number that tells you how much
something interacts via gravity
could have been different from the
number that tells you how reluctant
that object is to being accelerated but
for our universe
these two numbers are the same i mean
scientists to this day are still doing
very
delicate experiments to try to discern
any small
differences between these two but as far
as they can tell
to the best experiments up to date these
two numbers are exactly the same
even though they're conceptually
different so this is good to keep in
mind if you're going to do an experiment
you're going to be measuring either
inertial mass or gravitational mass
typically how would you know in a given
experiment if you measured one or the
other
well i mean if you just use a simple
experiment like take a spring scale
measure the force you're exerting on a
cart
and then measure the acceleration of
that cart using meter sticks and stop
watches
or a motion sensor and if you just plug
this into newton's second law
so if you know that acceleration from a
motion detector or
stop watches and rulers and you measure
the force with the spring scale
and you solve for this m well this
m is the denominator of newton's second
law that means you just solve for
inertial mass
because you solved in a formula that
contained inertial mass
how would you experimentally determine
the gravitational mass of this cart well
it's even easier
all you have to do take a scale you know
just a digital scale
take your cart put your cart on the
digital scale
and just measure how much the scale
reads because you know that the force of
gravity is going to be measured by the
scale
that's the number you get out of the
scales telling you how much weight
this object has so the scale will just
read this
and if you know what planet you're on
you know what g you've got so if you
know g is 9.8
and you solve for this m well look at
you solve for the gravitational mass how
much this thing interacts
via gravity so whenever you put
something on a scale weigh it like that
and get
m you're getting gravitational mass if
you do the other way with newton's
second law you're getting
inertial mass uh people get this mixed
up but it's pretty easy
if you ever use a formula that involves
little g or like
big g gravitational constant big g that
means
you've solved m in that formula for
gravitational mass if there isn't a g
then you're solving for inertial mass so
for instance maybe you do some
experiment where you try to
very delicately measure the force of
gravity between two spheres
this would be hard you probably wouldn't
set it up like this you'd have to be
more sophisticated but let's say you
could just
measure the force of gravity these two
spheres exert on each other
the formula for that would be big g m1
times m of the other divided by the
distance between them squared
you'd have to know one of the masses but
the spring scale could give you the
force
you can measure the distance between
them with a ruler g
big g you know it's a constant of the
universe if you knew one of the other
masses and solved for
this one you'd be getting the
gravitational mass look at you use the
formula
that's got big g any formula with big g
or with little g
like force of gravity is mg these are
all formulas that tell you how much the
object m is going to interact via
gravity
or you could even imagine gravitational
field
is big g m over r squared
all of these m's here this m here that m
there
that m there and this m here all
gravitational mass
because there's either big g or little g
involved in that fundamental
equation if there's a fundamental
equation that doesn't have big g or
little g
you're not talking about how something
interacts via gravity you're talking
about its inertia
and that would be inertial mass so for
instance if you did some other
experiment maybe you slam two carts
together and use conservation of
momentum
to solve for m well momentum is m v
this formula has nothing to do with
little g or big g no gravitational
constants here so if you use
this collision experiment and solve for
the mass of one of the carts
you've solved for the inertial mass of
the cart
similarly if you use kinetic energy this
formula has nothing
fundamentally to do with gravity
one-half mv squared there's no big g or
little g
this m here would be inertial mass uh if
you did the period of a mass on a spring
is two pi
root m over k there's no little g or big
g to be found in here that means this is
also inertial mass
so unless there's a little g or big g in
your fundamental equation here your
basic equation
that mass is going to be inertial mass
if there is a little g or big g you're
talking about gravitational mass
now if you're clever you could do a
single experiment with two
phases and get both masses at once for
instance
let's say you had a spring of known
spring constant and you hung a block on
it and you
lowered it gently until it hangs at a
certain distance unless you measured how
much did this thing stretch
well if you measure that with a ruler
then you know at this position
the spring force kx had better be equal
to the gravitational force mg and so kx
would just
equal mg if the spring constant's known
and you measured
x with a ruler and you know what planet
you're on because g is 9.8 on earth
if you solve for this m look at g's
right here you multiplied by the g and
this formula came from a gravitational
formula
you would have solved for gravitational
mass and now you know the gravitational
mass of the object
how could you get the inertial mass well
let's say you just pull down a little
extra
you pull this down a little extra you
let go and then it's going to oscillate
at a certain period let's say you
measure that period with a stopwatch you
measure how long it takes
to go through one full cycle that's got
to equal 2 pi
root m over k now there's no little g or
big g here this has nothing to do with
gravity so if you measure this period
with a stopwatch and you know the spring
constant and you solve for this
m well now you've solved for the
inertial mass
of that block and now you know both one
stage got us the gravitational mass
because it came from mg the m did uh the
second stage got us the inertial mass
because it comes from two pi
root m over k and this formula has
nothing to do with gravity so this would
be a way you could find
both masses at once so recapping
inertial mass and gravitational mass are
identical numbers
but different conceptually one tells you
how reluctant an object
is to being accelerated and the other
tells you how much the object will
interact via gravity
and if the mass shows up in a basic
formula that involves
little g or big g that's going to be the
gravitational mass
otherwise it's going to be the inertial
mass